Calvin Graham was the youngest of seven children
of a poor Texas farm family and because of
his abusive stepfather, he and one of his
older brothers decided to move out.
Calvin supported himself by selling newspapers
and delivering telegrams on weekends and after
school.
He was just eleven when he first thought of
lying about his age to join the Navy.
The world was in the midst of the second world
war and some of his cousins had recently died
in battles.
Graham made his decision.
The question was how to do it.
He started by shaving, as he thought it would
ultimately make him look older.
(And, note: Contrary to popular belief, shaving
has no effect on hair growth rates or thickness)
More effectively, he had his friends forge
his mother’s signature for consent, stole
a notaries’ stamp, and told his mom he was
going to visit relatives for a while.
Graham later recalled that the day he showed
up to enlist, “I stood 5’2 and weighed
125 pounds, but I wore one of my older brothers’
clothes and we all practiced talking deep.”
Despite all his efforts, there was one problem-
a dentist who helped screen the new recruits.
Graham stated, “I knew he’d know how young
I was by my teeth… when the dentist kept
saying I was 12, I said I was 17.
Finally, he said he didn’t have time to
mess with me and he let me go.”
On August 15, 1942, Calvin Graham was sworn
into the Navy.
He was twelve years, four months and twelve
days old, the youngest individual to enlist
in the U.S. military since the Civil War and
the youngest member of the U.S. military during
WWII.
After spending time in San Diego for basic
training, he sailed aboard the USS South Dakota
as a loader for a 40 mm anti-aircraft gun,
a “green boy” from Texas who would soon
become not only the youngest to serve, but
the nation’s youngest decorated war hero.
The South Dakota, known also as “Battleship
X” during the war, was a destroyer under
the command of Captain Thomas Leigh Gatch
that was heading to Guadalcanal, one of the
Solomon Islands in the South Pacific.
On the night of November 14, 1942, during
the Battle of Guadalcanal, the battleship
was hit forty-seven times by Japanese fire.
One explosion threw Calvin down three decks
of stairs.
He was seriously wounded by shrapnel that
tore through his face and knocked out his
front teeth.
Additionally, he suffered severe burns, but
in spite of his injuries he tried to rescue
fellow sailors from danger.
I took belts off the dead and made tourniquets
for the living and gave them cigarettes and
encouraged them all night.
It was a long night.
It aged me…
I didn’t do any complaining because half
the ship was dead.
For his efforts during the battle and aiding
other soldiers, despite his own injuries,
he received the Bronze Star as well as a Purple
Heart.
However, the distinction did not last long.
A year after serving in the Battle of Guadalcanal,
while his battleship was being repaired, Graham’s
mother learned of what her son had been up
to and informed the Navy of his real age.
Rather than simply releasing him from his
service, Graham was thrown in the brig for
almost three months.
It would seem the plan was to keep him there
until his service time was up, but he was
ultimately released when his sister threatened
to go to the media and tell them about her
brother’s imprisonment, despite his distinguished
service.
Graham was released, his medals stripped from
him, and then dishonorably discharged, which
is significant as it made it so he couldn’t
receive any disability benefits, despite his
injuries.
At only thirteen, Calvin Graham was a “baby
vet” who quickly found he didn’t fit in
at school anymore.
Once again he chose a life of an adult, getting
married and fathering a child at fourteen,
while working as a welder in a Houston shipyard.
At seventeen, he got divorced and enlisted
in the Marines.
Three years later, he broke his back when
he fell from a pier.
This unfortunate event ended his service career
and left him selling magazine subscriptions
for a living.
For the remainder of his life, Graham fought
for both medical benefits and a clean service
record.
In 1978, he was finally given an honorable
discharge (approved by President Jimmy Carter),
and all his medals except the Purple Heart
were reinstated.
He was also awarded $337 in back pay but was
denied health benefits except for disability
status for one of his two teeth he lost during
WWII.
In 1988, his story came to public attention
through the TV movie, Too Young the Hero.
The publication of his story pushed the government
to review his case and President Ronald Reagan
signed legislation that granted Graham full
disability benefits, increased his back pay
to $4917 and allowed him $18,000 for past
medical bills incurred due to injuries sustained
while a member of the military.
However, this was contingent on receipts for
the medical services.
Unfortunately, some of the doctors who treated
him had already died and many medical bills
were lost, so he only received $2,100 to cover
his former medical expenses.
Calvin Graham died of heart failure in November
of 1992, at his home in Fort Worth, Texas.
At the time of his death, all of his decorations
were reinstated with the exception of the
Purple Heart.
Two years later, his Purple Heart was reinstated
and presented to his widow at a special ceremony.
He also received the National Defense Service
Medal, Asiatic-Pacific Campaign Medal with
bronze Battle Star device and the WWII Victory
Medal.